the One Piece manga just confirmed one
of the most gamechanging theories about
Luffy's father because ladies and
gentlemen Mony D Dragon yes was a marine
that's right which means that we simply
must ask all sorts of questions such as
why did he join what rank was he did he
already have his devil fruit what made
him hate the world Nobles so much that
he eventually declared war on the entire
Celestial dragons how did he become the
most Wanted Man in the world like man
there's so much to talk about but
thankfully the chapter does give us a
reason why he left which is that he
realized that that was no real Justice
in the Marines but come on I mean let's
be real there has to be some truly
tragic or horrifyingly awful event that
actually sparked his desire to leave and
honestly by looking at his entire
timeline so far I do think that we can
actually figure out what that super
important event might have been but
before we get ahead of ourselves here
though let's start at the beginning here
on this handy timeline because to really
understand dragon's motivations we do
need to understand exactly where he has
been and it actually all starts when
Dragon was born 55 years before the
current story line and we're going to
assume that vice admiral garpo Luffy's
grandfather is actually his father even
though that's never actually been
confirmed officially in fact GARP only
ever said that Dragon was Luffy's father
not that Dragon was necessarily his son
so there is definitely room to speculate
that GARP is not even dragon's father
but for now let's assume that he is
garp's son then it makes a ton of sense
that GARP would want Dragon to also join
the Marines just like he later wanted
Luffy to only that other than Luffy this
time it seems that Dragon actually
listened to GARP instead of immediately
rebelling like Luffy did and I'm sure
that Garb was absolutely thrilled that
his son was following in his footsteps
but I also don't think that Dragon
joined just because of GARP because I
mean one thing that he clearly has is a
strong sense of justice that that he has
continued to believe in even after
leaving the marinees so there must have
been some sort of other inner motivation
for Dragon to actually join the Marines
in the first place and now while we
don't actually know precisely when he
joined I do think it's fairly reasonable
to assume that it was sometime as a late
teenager or maybe in his early 20s which
just happens to line up perfectly with
the god Valley incident actually more
specifically Dragon was 17 years old
during the events on God Valley so maybe
he did join up soon after that enormous
battle took place now what exactly could
have happened during his times in the
Marines well we don't really know for
sure of course but he simply must have
risen high enough in the ranks to
realize that there is no real Justice in
there because he probably isn't finding
out something lifechanging like that as
just a regular marine or an even lower
ranking officer and so I think one would
have to imagine that he became pretty
high ranked within the Marines probably
at least a vice admiral if not even an
admiral itself since these are the
Marines who actually do get tasked with
a lot of the Marines and the celestial
dragons dirty work and let me be real
here I would just love to see Marine
Admiral Dragon doing something truly
amazing plus Dragon does have this whole
green color scheme going on with his
robe and clothing and the wind power so
he would fit right into the Admiral
color themes and in fact he might have
been the first Admiral Greenbow or green
dragon I guess however after joining the
Marines the next actual confirmed
sighting of dragon in the story is this
scene right here which was 16 years
after the events of God Valley when
Dragon was 33 years old now at this
point he has already left the Marines
and formed the so-called Freedom
Fighters which we'll talk more about in
just a moment there's a lot more about
that in this chapter however when I read
this scene it does seem like the Freedom
Fighters have not been around for all
that long here so I would imagine that
Dragon was a marine until at least in
his late late 20s so maybe about 5 years
or so before this scene with Vega Punk
here but even more importantly this
scene gives us our most concrete clue
about why Dragon may have grown to hate
the celestial dragons and eventually
decided to leave the Marines before I
speculate about that though let's first
explain why some other common theories
for Dragon hating the world Nobles are
probably not true anymore at this points
for example one of the most common
theories why Dragon might hate the world
nobles was that they kill Luffy's mother
but after this chapter we can pretty
much cross out that idea mostly because
if you look up when Luffy was born
Dragon was already 36 years old which
was definitely way after he left the
Marines in other words that means Luffy
was actually born after Dragon had
already founded the Revolutionary Army
which actually brings back the idea that
jinny might be Luffy's mom not Bonnies
but hey more on that in just a moment as
well but first another common idea for
Dragon hating the world nobles was the
idea that he learned about the world
secret ruler emu however that was
basically already proven to be false
back in chapter 1086 and that's because
when Sabo explained that emu is the
secret ruler of the world to dragon and
Ivanov there was absolutely no hint
whatsoever that Dragon already knew
anything about this information which of
course it is possible that he was hiding
the info and pretending not to know it
but I think it's pretty unlikely at this
point so that's probably also not the
reasons that he left the Marine which
basically only leaves us with about two
or three very decent other reasons that
I can see for Dragon deciding to leave
the first is that the world Nobles
didn't actually kill Luffy's mom but
instead they killed dragon's mom which I
mean if we're going with the idea that
GARP is his actual father then that
could mean that they killed garp's wife
which again seems kind of unlikely
because I do feel an event like that
would even send someone like GARP on a
rampage to wipe out all of the world
Nobles himself but of course if dra
Dragon isn't Garb son then we have a
whole different situation here but I
still think it's kind of unlikely and so
maybe the most likely option at the
moment based on the timeline that we've
built and the events from chapter
1066 is that at some point Dragon met
the scholars of Ohara and learned some
of the true history of the world don't
believe me well during his meeting with
Vega Punk Dragon revealed that he
already knew Professor Clover who was
the leader of the scholars and was
desperately searching for information
about the void Century in fact we're
being told in that very same chapter
that Clover was arrested by the Marines
at least 10 times so wouldn't it just
make a lot of sense if Dragon was the
actual one who chased after Clover while
he was a marine you know kind of like
smoker chasing Luffy and if that was the
case I can easily imagine that Dragon
would become friends with this
adventurous scholar and even learn some
of the dark secrets about the world
government that Clover discovered on on
his journeys because I mean that same
marine and pirate Dynamic is also what
happened to GARP and the former pirate
king Goldie Roger where GARP chased
after Roger for years and they
eventually became somewhat like friends
I guess but on top of all of this Dragon
could have also met Nico alvia who was
also one of the scholars of aara and
Robin's mother okay no we're not going
to go down that rabbit hle but in fact
in chapter 593 we actually learned that
the Revolutionary Army and dragon have
been searching for Robin for over 10
years and they even call her the light
of the Revolution which is just even
more evidence that Dragon had a very
important relationship with Clover or
Olivia in the past and it fits together
very nicely that this relationship plus
maybe some other tragic event in his
past in the end spark dragon's desire to
defeat the celestial dragons or one more
bonus option maybe is that Dragon met
Roger at some point and learned the true
history of the world from him now this
is possible because Roger did find love
tale about 3 years before Dragon met
with Vega Punk on Ohara so I'm just
saying the timing and the timelines do
line up pretty well here plus I've
actually always been super curious how
dragon out of all these crazy people
that we know earned the highest bounty
in the entire world and while we don't
find out in this chapter we do know that
the one thing that the world government
absolutely does not allow is Research
into the poneglyphs Plus I've actually
always been super curious how dragon out
of all these crazy people that we know
earned the highest bounty in the entire
world and what we don't find out in this
chapter we do know that the one thing
that the world government absolutely
does not allow is Research into the
poneglyphs and so if Dragon was friends
with the people who did the research of
the poneglyphs or he got some info about
them from Roger then all of that plus
the fact that he's making an entire Army
to fight the world Noble and is a former
Marine could be enough reasons for him
to be have that super high Bounty and be
the most Wanted Man in the entire world
but in the end whichever of these
reasons actually sparked dragon's
decision to leave the Marines it's not
quite as important as what happens next
because as we learned from chapter 1066
and this chapter Dragon had already
formed the group known as the Freedom
Fighters which is essentially dragon's
group of rebels before he officially
founded the revolution AR Army and so in
chapter 1097 we finally get to see these
Freedom Fighters in action and that's
because about 16 years after Kuma and
jinny started Living on the islands the
ruler of the sorbet Kingdom basically
segregated the entire Island into a
section protected by the kingdom and a
section that is just basically Lawless
lands not only that but on top of that
there was also a massive tax placed on
the people to pay for the world
government's Heavenly tribute now this
whole story line might finally explain
how Kuma got his reputation as the
Tyrant King because even though he's
basically a priest for these people I
can honestly see the young Kuma rising
up to become sort of the boss or king of
this Lawless land which obviously the
upper class of this Kingdom wouldn't
want to see at all and he is put into
jail but soon after that dragon and
iankov here arrived with their band of
Freedom Fighters to overthrow this
corrupt ruler which finally leads to
Kuma and jinny joining up with the
Freedom Fighters which then officially
at this point become the Revolutionary
Army but from here on out though there
are actually a few new important points
that we can actually add to our timeline
for example in this chapter we learned
that 14 years ago Kuma and jinny were
confirmed to both still be a part of the
revolutionaries at this point in time
Kuma is 33 years old and jinny is 37 and
this fact by itself is actually super
interesting first of all again props to
jinny for surviving this long in the
story I mean I honestly thought that she
wouldn't even make it off God Valley but
the second really interesting point this
brings up is that we once again have to
reanalyze the question of is jinny
someone's mom I mean after last chapter
it did seem pretty logical that since
she and Kuma were living together then
jinny would eventually become Bunny's
mother right and I'd still say that it
might be one of the most likely options
since jinny already wanted to marry Kuma
in this same chapter I mean there's just
so many similarities between their name
their personalities but wait until you
hear the insane Theory coming up in just
a moment but before that though another
option is jinny being Luffy's mom which
after last chapter I thought that
wouldn't be the case but now that she
has been fully with the revolutionaries
for such a long time I mean honestly
Anything could happen between jinny and
Kuma or Jin and dragon which okay would
be kind of a weird love triangle to even
think about out so let's just go on to
the next option because then there is of
course the possibility that Bonnie might
be jinny's clone but now that we've
learned at the end of this chapter that
jinny has been kidnapped I'm kind of
starting to think that there might be
another mindblowing new possibility that
we hadn't even considered so far because
even though we don't know exactly when
on the timeline that jinny was kidnapped
we can reasonably guess that it was
sometime around 14 years before the
current story and so whenever this
occurred it gives us the perfect setup
for Kuma to become a warlord and a
government slave because if jinny was
captured by the world government then of
course Kuma is going to try and save her
maybe they wanted jinny for some sort of
devil fruit power or some other reason
but for now that reason isn't that
important honestly I keep saying I've
been surprised that jinnie has been
alive for this long but what if that is
because she was never actually dead in
the first place because yeah that's
right I'm proposing that Bonnie that we
have known for most of the story now is
in fact jinny who was aged down and had
her memories pushed out by Kuma which at
first sounds crazy yeah I know and while
she doesn't look exactly like Bonnie in
this chapter her appearance really isn't
that far off plus if you look deep
enough there is actually some pretty
solid evidence that supports this exact
idea first of all we do know that the
world government wanted Bonnie for some
reason and it does appear that they had
once captured her which honestly does
seem pretty weird knowing that she's
basically a pirate and we always saw her
as a young one at that but what if they
had actually captured her as jinny and
then they later let her go in exchange
for Kuma becoming the world government
slave but on top of that if you look
back to chapter 174 and the memories
that Bonnie viewed in the lab there are
some very odd circumstances surrounding
this as well first of all Vega Punk was
desperate for Bonnie not to see the
memories which was always a little bit
weird to me I mean yeah her father's
memories might have just been painful
but wouldn't it be good for Bonnie to
see what her father went through unless
of course these actually weren't Kuma's
memories but they were instead jinny's
memories and VAP Punk didn't want her to
realize that Bonnie isn't who she thinks
she actually is also in this flashback
that we thought was Kuma's Bonnie is
looking at Kuma from the outside which
wouldn't really make sense if they were
Kuma's memories in the first place
because if these were Kuma's memories
shouldn't the memories actually show a
perspective through his eyes instead we
kind of see it as if from someone else's
perspective looking at Kuma which would
make a lot more sense if these were
jinny's memories instead plus we were
also literally shown Bonnie turning Vega
Punk into a baby right before she
touched the memories which seems like
the sort of foreshadowing that Oda would
love to do however the one piece of
evidence that fits this Theory alt
together is this panel from chapter 9
eight so in case you don't remember this
this scene had Bonnie trying to sneak
into marijua in order to save Kuma but
going back and looking at it now I just
have to wonder how did she even know who
this Connie person was and that they
were the queen of Kuma's homelands
unless of course she actually once lived
there and had memories of this person
just like jinny did plus there's of
course the question of how she even
looks enough like this Connie person to
fool the guards but I don't have any
answer for that unless jinny was a
descendant of that ruling family family
or something like that which doesn't
seem like the case from this last
chapter but yeah jinny might be a mother
but she also might very well be still
alive as Bonnie and we just never knew
about it but even more so with all of
this talk of dragon the Marines and the
revolutionaries I do really wonder if
dragon's story of being a marine and
later leaving will be the model for
another Marine to flip sides in the
future as well I mean a really easy
choice for this would be Kobe but
honestly I see him more as following
into garp's footsteps than dragons I
mean Kobe literally dreams of being a
marine Admiral and he trained under GARP
plus GARP basically gave up his life to
save Kobe so yeah I do see Kobe as
trying to get rid of the corruption from
within the Marines rather than from the
outside which means that the perfect
candidate is actually vice admiral
smoker here I mean if you look at his
entire character Arc which has just led
him to uncovering more and more of the
government's corruption then it would
just make sense that eventually he
wouldn't be able to take any more of it
and he will choose to leave the Marines
by himself and at this point I just
wonder what event might actually tip him
over the edge and make him possibly even
become a pirate or join the
revolutionaries but what's even more
exciting though is that the flashback
isn't even over yet so in the next few
chapters we might even get to see dragon
fully show off his powers for the very
first time and well this is like one of
those Mysteries that I've been desperate
to know about for so long because he
just has to be right one of the top tier
Powerhouse in the entire story and if
you want to know what his legendary
Powers might actually be plus the
unknown powers of other extremely strong
fighters in the story then you can check
out this video right here Shanks for
watching and I will see you in the next
one